Ви переїхали в нову країну і хочете працювати за фахом.
Але не можете, бо тут не визнають ваш диплом.
Ця проблема знайома багатьом приїжджим,
які вдома мали значний досвід і кваліфікацію.
Виходить, на новому місці все треба починали з нуля?
Коли я був у Сирії, мій друг, який мав великий досвід зварювання,
сам усього мене навчив.
А потім я отримав роботу, і вже в компанії набив собі руку.
Я ніколи не отримував жодної формальної підготовки.
Всі доступні курси були або надто спеціалізованими,
або занадто далеко від мене.
Без офіційної кваліфікації або сертифікатів
отримати роботу в Німеччині, як правило, дуже складно.
Такий стан речей прагне змінити Федеральне агентство зайнятості.
Зараз випробовують новий тест.
Він триває чотири години, під час яких людина показує -
чи знає технічні ноу-хау і які має практичні навички.
Це дуже швидко і водночас все дуже чітко.
Тобто місцеві агентства з працевлаштування
більше не мають покладатися лише на резюме або співбесіду.
Адже ви отримуєте дуже конкретні науково обґрунтовані результати
перевірки придатності до певної роботи.
Поки тести існують лише для восьми професій -
від кухаря до майстра з обробки металу.
Після здачі тесту Валід Рагб
одразу ж отримав роботу у німецькій металургійній компанії.
Допоміг результат тесту, який переконав нового роботодавця.
Пан Рагб отримав найвищі бали.
Результати тесту дуже докладні, тож ми чітко зрозуміли:
у нього є те, що нам потрібно. Він розуміється на матеріалах,
з якими він працює і він знає теорію.
Валід Рагб каже, що зварювальні апарати
а стандарти роботи в Німеччині відрізняються від тих,
з якими він мав справу удома.
Однак після двох місяців додаткового профнавчання
він почувається впевнено.
Через кілька днів вже буде перше замовлення на виїзді.
Зараз найбільший виклик для нового працівника - німецька мова.
Безперечно, буде важко на початку.
Однак, в мене є контракт, тож з часом все налагодиться.
Важливо вивчати мову.
Вона повинна стати другою рідною для мене.
Ви маєте вивчати мову,
щоб мати змогу брати участь у місцевому житті.
Німеччина зараз - як моя друга батьківщина.
Найближчим часом німецька влада планує
розширити тест на професійні здібності до 30 професій.